[Müzik]
bir kitap var 2015'te yayınlandı Dünyada
daha önce sevgili Einstein'ın torunu
tarafından derlenmiş 2015'te de
Türkiye'de basılmış kitaplardan bir
tanesi sevgili Einstein
Einstein'ın işte Çocuklarla olan ömrü
boyunca işte birbirlerine mektuplar
gönderiyor onlardan derlenmiş bir
kitap çok etkiledi beni Güney Afrikalı
tiffani diyor ki sevgili Profesör
Einstein Ben bir bilim insanı olmak
istiyorum ama inşallah kız olduğum için
beni yadırgamaz küçük
görmezsiniz
1946 aradan Bir ay geçiyor Einstein
diyor ki sevgili ti ben küçümsemiyorum
Ama daha önemli bir şey var As sen
küçümseme belisin Çünkü bunun için
hiçbir sebep
yok Tiffany'nin ne olduğunu bilmiyorum
Daha sonra bayağı araştırdım ama sevgili
Google bana bu konuyla ilgili çok bir
bilgi vermedi bilenler olursa lütfen
Sonrasında bana
söylesin şimdi 1940'lardan bahsediyorum
Halbuki o zamana gelene kadar aslında
işte cyer var rosalin Franklin var İşte
buradaki sevgili
eee
bilim insanları bilim kadınları var Şu
josephine bulaşık makinesini icat
eden kadın hikayesi çok komik Sadece şu
kadarını söyleyeyim
yardımcısı var Ve evde sürekli Porselen
takımları kırıyor muu yardımcısı
Dolayısıyla kadın caz da demiş ki e
bıktım artık kırmasın Ben kendime bir
şey icat edeyim deyip bulaşık makinesini
öyle icat etmiş insanlardan biri şimdi
1940'larda tiin şeyine gelene kadar işte
1800'lerde bulaşık makinesi sonrasında
araba sileceğinin bir kadın tarafından
icat edildiğini Ben de bu konuşmaya
hazırlanırken öğrendim bu arada sevgili
Mary Anderson ya da güneş enerjisi
sistemi Maria hepsini saygıyla yad
edelim şimdi 1940 dedik
aradan 100 yıla yakın zaman geçti değil
mi Ben de bir baktım dedim ki tede
gidiyorum şu datalara bir bakayım ama
sizi dataya boğmaya korkmayın sadece
birkaç tane böyle o yüzyılda neler
değişmiş ondan bahsetmek istiyorum şimdi
sistem alanında çalışan kadınlara bir
bakayım dedim ne olmuş en
son % 28 Dünyada yani bu işte Fen
Matematik Teknoloji bilim alanında
çalışan kadınlar % 28 bu dünya için Eee
Avrupa ülkelerine baktım Biraz daha bu
şeyler
kaymış ekran azizliği diyelim % 17'ler
de Avrupa
Birliği'nde Türkiye'de de % 122 yani
işte stem alanında çalışan % 122 lik bir
kitle var bu Bu arada 2023 verisi Hatta
Mart verisi çok taze taze bir şeyden
bahsediyorum Sonra dedim ki ya Tamam Çok
da fazla kadın çalışmıyor Eee Peki bu bu
alanı öğrenmek isteyenler de durum ne
gittim Biraz böyle işte demin yüdemi
dendi B de bir corser datası vardı ona
bir bakayım dedim Orada da dünyada % 39
Heh ben bu işi öğreneyim diyor
Türkiye'de de oran hiç fena değil % 31
kadınlar özelinde söylüyorum gayet güzel
ama işi
mutfağından hala çok
uzağız % 4 gibi bir eee veri var elimde
kadınların % 4'ü sadece İşte bu Yapay
Zeka ya da işte otomasyon veya işte
makine öğrenmesiyle ilgileniyor geri
kalan daha böyle bir iş analisti işte
kimya fizik onlarla ilgili eğitim Almaya
karar vermiş görünüyor Şimdi ben bunun
nedenini birkaç böyle işte yerden
sorguladım bunlardan bir tanesi de işte
science dergisiyle uçan süpürge kadın
iletişim Derneği var onların verilerine
baktım arkadaş neden dedim ya hani Evet
100 yıl önce öyleydi Şimdi neden böyle
Eee bayağı onların dilinden yansıtmaya
çalıştım bir bir bir şey diyorlar Bir
kere insanlar Eee Yalnız kalacağım Çünkü
sınıfta işte 50 kişilik sınıf var ve
sadece ü tanesi Kız ve gerisi erkek ne
yapacağım eğlenceli değil Çünkü işte
içinde makyaj yok işte içinde Ne bileyim
müzik yok işte böyle motamot e eş MC
kare mi göreceğim bir kısım diyor
ki rol modelim Yok ya Benim ailemde
bilimle ilgili herhangi bir kadın yok
ki bir kısım diyor ki bu erkek işi
arkadaş yani kafam basmaz benim Bunu
diyen çok sayıda insan var Bu arada
science dergisinin araştırması çok
güzeldi o anlamda diyor ki işte kafam
basmaz deyip yelmed imde Aslında
sınavlardaki başarıları kadınların
erkeklere göre daha fazla ama
yönelmiş kadınlar dinledim hepsiyle de
bir kadın olarak gurur duydum ben o
teknolojini sadece işte kariyer mentoru
tarafında ve teknoloji kullanıcısı bir
kadınım ama kullansak demek ki
Becereceğim Bunu niye
önemsiyorum şu yüzden önemsiyorum
aslında da Eee cinsiyet eşitliği Evet
gelir eşitsizliği Evet işte kadınların
dünya üzerindeki yerleri Evet ama çok
daha kritik bir şey var aslına
bakarsanız benim önemsemenin sebebi de
bu şimdi Demin konuştuk işte önümüzdeki
10 yılda dünyada işte Yapay zeka
Otomasyonu yla 600 milyon insan işsiz
kalacak ama daha kötüsü ne biliyor
musunuz Onun bir 1 bu5 katı yani
kadınların işsiz kalmasıyla erkeklerin
işsiz kalması arasındaki dengesizlik
beni çok rahatsız etti kadınlar bir
buçuk kat daha fazla
tehlikede Şimdi şöyle bir baktım dedim
ki ya otomasyonda En çok neler gidecek
çıkanlar
Eee perakende işte satış temsilcileri
mağazadaki satışçı kızlarımız kasiyerler
imiz Eee bankadaki gişeler gişe
memurlarımız işte eee muhasebe veri
girişi yapanlar stok gidiyor Bu
meslekler Tamam şimdi burada çalışan
kadınla erkeği zaten pembe mavi diye çok
klasik bir şekilde göstermeye çalıştım
gördüğünüz gibi oran çok fazla yani Şunu
demek istiyorum ki 10 kadından 8i ha bu
otomasyon yüzünden işsiz kalacak yani
dünyadaki erkeklerden çok daha fazla
konuyu bu yüzden önemsiyorum aslına
bakarsanız ş çıkarttım bir anne şapkası
taktım şimdi size E demin Bora bahsetti
İşte bizim bir ay sonra 4 yaşına basacak
Bir oğlumuz var Dolayısıyla ben bir
erkek çocuğu annesi olarak bu şapkayla
Demin bahsettiğim şapkayla şimdi 4 yaşa
bakıyorum
Eee biliyoruz ki araştırıyoruz ki ya
Bugün işte ilkokulda olanların % 65'i
başka mesleklerde çalışacak Burası
aşikar bu kafayla diyorum ki ya diyorum
Benim oğlan ne yapacak onun arkadaşları
ne yapacak O ne yapacak bu ne yapacak
Eee deli gibi şey araştırmaya başladım
bu stem konusunda işte eğitim veren
kurumlar işte 4 yaş çocuğuna ne yapılır
ne edilir falan diye işte sosyal medyada
bakıyorum Google'da bakıyorum orada
bakıyorum burada bakıyorum şöyle ilanlar
görüyorum Evet okul öncesi robotik
kodlama Baş diyor Şimdi burada ne
dikkatinizi çekiyor Bunlar
ilan hiç kız yok Allah Allah reklam
arkadaş bu kız gelmeyecek mi
buraya Neyse Geçen hafta bir tanesine
götürdüm Bizimkine Ondan sonra bu şey
yaptılar işte böyle legolardan işte bir
denizaltı yapmaya çalıştılar falan
burada zaten çok mutsuz gördüğünüz gibi
Çünkü beceremedi yani o şeyi o yüzden de
kendi kötü hissetti Şimdi sınıfta seiz
çocuk var bir tane kız var Tamam onu da
annesi zorla alıp getirmiş herhalde
oraya dedim ki
şey klasik Yani bu bu Hikaye Böyle
işliyor Biz Bada Ben de zaman zaman
Oğlumuzu sürekli çekeleye çekeleye stem
etkinliklerine götürüyoruz Tamam burada
üç tane fotoğrafını paylaştım farklı
etkinlikler bunlardaki durum aynı yani
ya bir kız var ya hiç yok
Tamam Dolayısıyla zaten Bu minik
Veletler Bu erkek dediklerimiz bunları
göre göre büyüyor Tamam Bu iş kız işi
değil nereden kaynaklanıyor hani biz her
ne kadar evlerimizi açtık diyelim Ama
gördüğü şey bu ve bu beni çok rahatsız
ediyor
Eee bilim müzesine gittik Pazar Günüydü
zaten çok az insan vardı
10 aile ya vardı ya yoktu
hiç kız aile görmedim hiç kız çocuğu
Ailesi görmedim Ali Kuşçu uzay kampına
gittik bir tane iki tane kız çocuğu
gördüm O da işte böyle güneş sistemi
falan onların şeyinde Ama yakalayamadık
karelerde yine erkek çocuğu
gördük oyuncak almaya gidiyoruz bu hafta
çektim Bunu bizim oradaki herhangi bir
oyuncakçı şimdi şuraya bir Baksanıza
roketler var En solda roketler neyin
yanında araba Tamam roket oyuncaklar
arabaların yanında stem bölümü yapmışlar
neyin yanında traktörlerin
yanında şeyler var robotlar var
silahların yanında Burası neresi
oyuncakçıda erkek bölümü ha Bu da bizim
bölüm bebekler çamaşır makineleri bilmem
neler falan filan Şimdi şey alacak
arkadaşına hediye alacağız doğum gününe
şey Okula götürecek dedim ki oğlum dedim
gel dedim Şu robottan alalım dedim ona
işte Lina adı Kızcağızın dedi
ki Nasıl yani dedim ki oğlum robot
alalım işte bak O da işte eğlenecek Bak
burada şarkı söyle basıyorsun falan bir
şeyler diyor robot dedi ki iyi de o kız
Ya arkadaş dünkü Vitamin ne kızı ne
erkeği Sen
kimsin
almadı
yani gitti yine böyle bir çamaşır
makinesi bir ş bir şey seçti almadı
ısrar etmedim dedim ki ha ben bir de
gideyim stem oyuncaklarına
bakayım Google'da aradım buraya
geleceğim diye yine bin bir hevesle
şimdi stem
oyuncakları ne var
burada Şimdi benim oğlan haklı mı değil
mi peki
Barbie bunu birazcık kırmış biraz biraz
yeni yeni kariyer sevisi yapmış Bunlar
da Barbie'nin şeyleri e robotik kodlama
şeyleri işte bir tane de böyle astronotu
var bir tane bir şeyi var falan
Türkiye'de göremedim sadece yine böyle
yurt dışından araştırdığım kadarıyla
gördüm hah dedim En azından bir şeyler
olacak
gibi kendi küçük çevremde velilerle
konuşuyorum dedim ki ya dedim ne
etkinliklere götürüyorsunuz ben bizim
oğlanı işte bakıyorum hafta sonu falan
tutamıyorum zaten adamı Adam şuramda
olduğu için ya buraya gelirken bile 5
kişiye bırakıp geldim buraya Dolayısıyla
dedim ki Ya ben bunu tutamıyorum ne
yapıyorsunuz müzik resim İşte bu belirli
bir ağırlıkla yapmadım Bunu işte bale
jimnastik şu bu falan filan okey stem
var
mı yani stem derken bu arada e eşittir
mce kare demiyorum tekrar söylüyorum
Yani bunun içinde doğayla bütünleşme de
olabilir bunun içinde işte bir deney de
olabilir yani mutlaka ki bir robot alıp
çocuğa ver ve onunla eğlensin demiyoruz
ama bunu
önemsiyorum şimdi diyorum ki o yüzden
burada genç bir nüfus var ama hani
konuşma yayınlanacak beni izleyen
anneler babalar buradaki ablalar abiler
işte eee e yarın öbür gün çocuğu
olacaklar Aman Hani herkes şey derler ya
her şeyi hükümetten beklemeyin devletten
beklemiyor falan ya gerçekten ne okuldan
Bekleyelim ne başkasından bekleyelim ya
Önce hani hakikaten bizim bir Elimizi
taşın altına koyma zamanı Tamam kız
kardeşiniz varsa Kız kardeşiniz
Çocuğunuz varsa öyle Çünkü önce görmek
istedikleri şey A evet bir rol model var
gelecek gin mesleklerini bilen bir rol
modelim var benim ablam öyle ya işte
babam öyle Annem öyle şimdi geleceğin
mesleklerinde ne var ne istiyor bizden
yaratıcılık istiyor Eee problem çözme
istiyor işte demin Boro bahsetti yine
şey problem çözmede kadınlar daha son
Evet çünkü ben arada bir taraftan işte
Ege pırasa mı yedi bilmem ne mi yedi
işte buradan nasıl döneceğiz çekin
yapıldı mı ya biz zaten iyiyiz ve çok
Komplike şeyleri çözebiliyor Tamam
onların da bunu görmeye ihtiyacı var o
yüzden önce evin içindeki rol modellere
ihtiyaç var
Tamam Pamuk Prenses dedim Çünkü öyle
sesleniyoruz çocuklarımıza işte erkek
çocuklara prensim öbürlerine prenses bir
uyandırmaya ihtiyacımız var Nasıl
diyelim ki deneyler yaparak değil mi
İşte şey O deminki yetkinliklere göre
yazdım bunları dedim ki mesela işte
deney yapıyoruz evde Yani şunu
istemiyorum sizden sodaya katın oradan
bilmem ne tüp patlasın falan değil ya
Bırakın bir tane onun üstüne Tamam
karabiber döksün üstüne bilmem ne döksün
İlla bir kek yapıyorsanız şeker
kullanmasın bir sorsun bakalım ya şeker
yerine ne kullansak ya dedi ki işte ne
bileyim ben
çökelek bilmiyorum Hadi deneyelim Hadi
deneyelim Hadi deneyelim biz izin
vermediler
Eee 80 doğumluyum hiçbir şey denememize
İzin vermeyen bir nesilden lütfen
denemelerine keşfetmelerine izin
verdiğimiz bir yere gidelim burada
yazılar çıkmamış Ben sunumun
yansımasının Kurbanıyım Ama genel olarak
özetlemeye çalıştığım şey bu bir önemli
şey daha söyleyeceğim size o da şu e
bilgisayar oyunu size ne ifade
ediyor erkek değil mi arabalar Bilmem
vurdular Kırdılar falan bir araştırma
yapılmış bilgisayar oyununa Eee
oynayanların ileride Eee stemle ilgili
bir şey seçmeleri 4 kat daha fazla
kızlardan bahsediyorum Tamam işin içine
Biraz girsinler biraz baksınlar bırakın
birazcık kurcalar öğrensinler Hepimiz
için geçerli şimdi şu konu Aslında bilim
işte her şey Yani işsiz kalmaları falan
değil konu
benim için daha önemli olan şey hayal
ettikleri Bir şeyi yapabilme şanslarının
olacak olması de Mühendislik öyle bir
şey hayal ettim ben ya illa köprü yapmam
gerekmiyor saçımın bir tarafını kıvırcık
bir tarafını düz yapacak bir şey hayal
ettim ve onu yapabiliyorum asıl önemli
olan şey bu hayal ettiğin şeyi
yapabilmeye muktedir olmak ve tabii ki
dünyanın da erkeklere olduğu kadar
kadınlara da da temiz su için
sürdürülebilirlik için ve Eee
yaratıcılık konusunda ihtiyaçları
var
şimdi ben derim ki bizim kızlardan
yaratıcılar çıkar
Eee çok yönlü insanlar çıkar sanatçılar
çıkar bilim insanları çıkar inşallah
Filenin Sultanları gibi bir gün öyle bir
hayalim var ki bilimin Sultanları çıksın
ve Biz de yine böyle alkış saha
geliyorlar dünya bir numarası sahaya
geliyor Çok teşekkür ederim sağ
[Alkış]
olun